on his show on Friday he had a rather
curious statement related to what's
going on with DeSantis and Trump and I
think he sort of almost accidentally
made the argument that I've been making
for quite some time so here's this from
Fox News Real Time host Bill Maher
advised Florida Governor Ron DeSantis to
avoid the battle in the mud with former
president Donald Trump in the 2024
election cycle as reports indicate he
will enter the race for the White House
I personally think that would be a
mistake for him Mar began a panel
discussion on Friday because he's 46 I
think just let Trump die politically I
mean or you know he's older it could
happen I'm not wishing it but okay he'd
still only be 50. Mark continued if
DeSantis got in against Trump trump will
do to him what he does to everybody not
just bloody him it'll be a battle in the
mud and all DeSantis has to do is wait
and he can be president I normally would
say the opposite get in early before
they pick you apart but in this case
with trump it changes everything GOP
pollster Kristen soltis Anderson
compared running against Trump to
running into a wood chipper but
disagreed with Mar that DeSantis should
wait it out since this is his moment you
don't get your moment all the time in
American politics soltis Anderson said
so what's interesting about this guys
and and again you know my feelings about
Mars so we don't have to you know we
don't have to rehash that it only is
worth listening to Mars opinion on this
if Mar honestly was going to vote for
DeSantis but I think sadly what Mar is
doing there and again I saw him last
week I like the guy so this is not a
personal attack Bill and I'm we're going
to play basketball at your house okay
this is not a personal attack but I am
fairly certain no matter whether it's
Trump or DeSantis you're going to vote
for the Democrat so really what you are
doing here is saying much more about
your intentions you want the weaker
candidate to run on the Republican side
and you view the weaker candidate As
Trump which actually is correct DeSantis
is the guy that can bring the moderates
DeSantis is the guy that can bring
the the disaffected Liberals and young
people like we know who's the new person
that's going to suddenly move to Trump
so Mars doing something it's like you're
advising DeSantis but I would only take
if I was this at this I would only take
advice from people that want to help me
not people that want to kneecap me and
that is the problem with what Bill
Maher's line of thinking there is
although as you guys know when I did
Bill Maher's podcast I got him to admit
he would move to Florida if California
ever came crashing down again when it
comes to lockdowns and mandates and all
of that stuff
um but I think you see it Bill Maher
again this is a guy that a week before
the election was saying if you if you
you know for all the stuff he gets right
on wokeness and free speech and all that
stuff he basically two three days before
the midterms was saying if you want to
save democracy you got to vote for
Democrats so why would DeSantis or any
sane Republican take uh his advice I
just don't know
thank you
[Music]